so i figured that we could rent a big
huge rv
and and we're all going to go up one
happy family in the rv
are you serious this sounds like a
disaster
how are all of us going to be able to
fit into an rv
these rvs can hold like 18 or 20 people
i mean he's expecting us to go on a
15-hour
rv ride together
we can't just park and get out like
that's not how it goes so
i don't know i like screams
red flags to me for sure let's just
do something fun spontaneous fun we're
going to be a family
we're going to be together we're going
to love each other the family business
is not going to destroy our family
i don't want to get stuck with this
siblings of libya's and
is kind of crazy but at the time in time
it's good idea to build up some
relationship with chuck
and to get closer and actually you know
like
have a normal uh father-in-law
son-in-law
relationship but you're wanting all of
us to go together when there's like
issues going on with him and you guys in
the business
and stuff like that like there's two
ways you can look at it like
glass half empty glass half full glass
half full
is we get to spend two days yeah if we
all got along
two days in an rv who was the guy who's
trying to take advantage of you
after everything that's happened like
i'm good i don't give a [ __ ] spending
the time with you
i'm not driving up on the rv with y'all
what the with everybody like jogging on
my husband i don't understand
what did he ever do to you guys try to
take advantage of our dad
yeah how is he taking advantage of him
how is he not
you get it's not working and then when
he's working you have a big issue with
him he's not worried about him working
he's he doesn't want to work that's his
problem hold up hold on a second this is
not what i had in mind
we didn't come out here to do this he's
a manipulator he's a municipality
you're seriously the fact that you're
bringing lions into the lions
you are two families you have two
faces do you not see what's going on
with your husband and dad
you have no clue you don't put your hand
in my
face you don't
talk to my husband talk to my husband
that way
people now like this is your family